comment tu es venu en métro en passant
par les stations salazar et ensuite
enfin de champerret s je vais tout
déchirer j'espère bien d'en bas tout
quand même
[Musique]
j'ai travaillé avec le corps avec un
acteur qui qu'un acteur qui apprendrait
pas tellement son texte mais qui est
très bon et l'improvisation et surtout
et ça c'est très important
le premier jour j'ai vu que benjamin
était content d'être là et ça pour moi
c'était la clé de toute la suite c'est à
dire que un acteur de prendre du plaisir
à jouer
sinon il a rien à [ __ ] sur un plateau
[Musique]
oula une science qui ne connaît même pas
je l'aï su directement créer un lien
avec des enfants dans un appartement
j'existais c'est bon c'est le bon gars
après mais dans ma tête j'ai oublié
qu'il était acteur ce que je crois que
je recrutais intention de réaliser et en
fait non après je suis revenu dans le
dans la fiction dit mince et du cinéma
en fait vincent il a pris en quelques
jours un ce que nous on a appris en 20
ans hélas du génie je vous regarde et je
vous observez des 10 rb c'est vrai il me
regarder mais tout ils lèvent tous fait
tenues vestimentaires touche pas comment
il a fait c'est pas que directeur qu'il
est bon chacun son métier les cqp avec
des autistes ou cours by stéphane meca
complexe vous dire qu'on prend des
jeunes qui sont pas en institution bien
qu'ils l'ont été mais qu'ils ne sont
plus et depuis ils ne l'ont jamais été
parce que institutionnellement parlant
c'est compliqué de les prendre en charge
on accompagne ces jeunes là dans les
activités dites de monsieur madame tout
le monde le but c'est de leur offrir une
société une socialisation et d'inclusion
dans la société à travers des activités
qui sont ici ne bruit cinéma enfin vous
vincent avant d'arriver sur ce projet
est ce que vous aviez vous étiez
sensibilisés à cette problématique qui
peut y avoir autour de la prise en
charge des personnes avec autisme
j'étais au courant de rien comme je
tairai 98 % des gens circle un je ne
sais pas ce qu est l autisme j'en avais
une espèce de vision un peu romancée par
hollywood avec le film rain man
en gros le raccourci c'est les autistes
sont tous des super données surdoué mais
ce n'est pas le cas de tout le monde et
surtout je ne savais pas en fait que
c'était pas pris en charge comme il
fallait je savais pas qu'il y avait des
gens qui étaient complètement livrés
même que sa gelée découvert en fait le
poulet la vocation de ce film c'est
justement que le grand public se rendre
compte de ça c'est qu'en fait les
autistes ne sont pas pris en charge
quand il faut qu'on existait des cas
trop lourd en france dont le diagnostic
c'est moi j'ai eu l'assistance sociale
et les mineurs et demandant le placement
j'ai dit si bien aucun jour
trouver une solution j'ai commencé par
je pense par me mettre dans un espèce de
truc un peu déplacé de pitié ou de
compassion inutile et puis au bout d'un
moment je me suis dit il faut que
j'arrive à avoir cette cette distance
qu'ils ont parce que ils sont toujours
touchés par ce qu'ils voient tous les
jours sauf qu'ils savent comment dealé
avec donc voila moi j'ai jeu d'un point
de vue purement acteurs je me suis
rapproché d'eux pour apprendre à avoir
le contact crédible auprès de ces jeunes
et puis sur le chemin bas je me suis
rendu compte qu'en fait il faut donner
de soi et du coup on nous rapporte tout
simplement bateau ça faut pas se tromper
assez les enfants qui ont une forme à
l'autisme et pas le contraire
c'est des enfants mais voilà tranquille
avec ça mais le film va nous dire si des
citoyens nos concitoyens vont comprendre
leur rôle à eux parce qu'ils ont un rôle
à jouer je crois que c'est le plus
important
si le film le succès qu'on espère
il sera ça sera impossible pour les
politiques de l'éviter en fait
parce que ce qui devient populaire
forcément tout est pris en compte
donc on verra mais
politique sociale
on espère c'est à dire que de toute
façon c'est sain c'est une question qui
est sociétale aujourd'hui le monde de
l'autisme et le fait que la france a été
condamnée plusieurs fois dessus donc ça
peut être de la politique revendicatif
peut-être de la politique sociale on en
fera peut-être de la politique
politicienne
en attendant ce qu'on espère c'est que
les politiciens soient à l'air dessus et
c'est aussi l'une des fonctions du
cinéma c'est aussi ça
[Musique]